how can people begin to attract the life
that they want to bring abundance into
your life you have to be cultivating an
abundant mindset and so a really easy
way to start is to list the things that
you're grateful for that you already
have and as part of attracting things
into your life or manifestation you know
imagine it being true imagine what it
would look like feel like smell like and
then when you have that Vision in your
mind give gratitude for it becoming true
so then it sets you on a path of I'm
grateful for the things that I've got
these are the things that I want and
you're staying positive and abundant and
grateful and that's much more likely to
attract those good things into your life
hey it's s Carmichael and I make these
videos because I need them from me
because I want to wake up every day and
watch a video that puts me in a mindset
to believe in myself more and go off and
accomplish amazing things and attack the
day and I hope that this video does that
for you as well so today let's learn how
to master your thinking to shape your
reality
enjoy
rule number two is be intentional with
Deepak Chopra intention and attention in
the field of infinite
possibilities is all that matters
intention and intention in the field in
field of infinite
possibilities have the intention of what
you want to create with the abundance
you have and then with that
intention um go and uh trans send and
when you transcend you transcend to the
source and there are many ways of
transcending through music through a
walk in nature through uh poetry through
dance through um whirling through
meditation through um play and uh
through um uh Collective uh what I call
Collective uh
envisioning Collective envisioning when
you have a group of people who have a
vision together when you have an open
system when you're uh um totally
transparent when
um um you
invite um even absurd ideas when you
make unlikely connections then something
emerges and we call that emergence so um
create a
group um for wealth Consciousness and if
you create that group and if you're
transparent and if you invite unlikely
alliances if you have maximum diversity
of people from the Arts from the
humanities from
Sciences from any field technology
mathematics whatever and um
you sit and incubate together
with attention and intention then
emergence happens just happens and the
emergence of abundance in this case with
the proper uh attention and intention
and even Collective intention I know
somebody in New York who just raised
$450 million through crowd sourcing um
for creating a place for um spiritual
enlightenment uh but this is how they
did IT Crowd sourcing with
authenticity with
sincerity with
integrity and with joy rule number three
is shift your thinking with Louise Hay
so many people think that money is the
most important thing in the world and if
they don't have money they would just
die but that's not true there's a
substance that is far more precious and
far more important to us that we
literally can't live without what is
that love love no appar plenty of people
are miserable and lonely most of their
life and and and live air air your air
your breath your breath is the most
important thing that you have the most
precious thing if you didn't take
another breath you wouldn't last 3
minutes and you'd never get out of this
room and yet we absolutely take for
granted that our next breath is there
look at us we're all in this room
breathing and I'm not saying don't
breathe there's not enough for me we
assume that it's there and when we
exhale we don't think about where's my
next breath coming
from
now if the power that created us has
given us enough breath to last for as
long as we shall live can we not begin
to trust that the other things will take
care of care of themselves see life is
here for us life is here to support us
to take care of us to be here for us the
entire planet has been put here for us
to play with we have everything that we
shall ever need it's already here only
we have to know it and we have to trust
it and we have to acknowledge it do you
realize that there is more food on this
planet than people could possibly eat
there's an incredible amount of food yes
it is true that there are people
starving but the food is
here there is more money on this planet
then we know how to count the money is
here now there are lots of people who
are very broke but the money is
here there are billions of people on
this planet and yet you will have people
tell you that they're
lonely it has nothing to do with not
being people it's what we're doing with
our heads everything is here for us for
every disease on this planet there is a
plant that'll cure
it everything everything is here for us
and the more we begin to trust life and
acknowledge the beauty and magnificence
of our own being the more we find
everything we need it just pops up also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is use your
imagination with Bob Proctor I set a
goal in
1973 I set a goal that I was going to
build a company that operate all over
the
world I had uh left the Nel K
Corporation and decided that I was going
to do this because I didn't agree with
the way they were doing it people
weren't really learning it fast enough
uh they wouldn't get involved in the
repetition we were selling recordings
but the recordings weren't working
because the people didn't understand how
to use them so I decided I would leave
and start my own company and I wrote
down I'd build a company that operated
all over the world I got a call last
night from Mikey about 9:00 something
like that and um she told me that we
were now in every country in the
world now think of
that we had a broadcast going on on here
at 10:00 this morning some of you'd be
familiar with it some of you may have
been on it and
um that broadcast had attracted
thousands literally thousands of
people from every country in the world
the goal was
reached that move meant this is really
accurate today we're only limited by
weakness of attention and Poverty of
imagination well my imagination was
pretty well exercised I don't have any
difficulty building huge ideas in my
mind and just figuring out how to do it
now stay with me
here the thing that's stopping you from
taking the risk that you want to take is
called a terror
barrier the way I'm going to explain
this to you I come up with sitting in a
restaurant I remember it was at a
Holiday In Restaurant it was at Dixie
and uh just sou of to the 401 Highway in
Toronto a man asked me if I would meet
with him he had a problem and um I was
going to show him how he could solve the
problem and he explained it so I took a
pen and some paper and what I'm going to
show you here is essentially what I
showed
him now look at this for a moment there
is the process you go through when
you're in a risk-taking vibration you go
from
bondage to reason
to the terror barrier and then to
Freedom you go from
bondage to
reason to the terror barrier and then to
Freedom rule number five is fully
express yourself with Neil Donald Walsh
98% of the world's people are spending
98% of their time on things that don't
matter that's true on things that have
nothing to do with why we're here yeah
we get caught up in our doing this oh
you don't understand I'm a
cameraman that's what I do I'm a I'm an
audio technician that's what I do no you
don't understand I I do interviews you
know I write books that's what I do but
those doing this functions are
meaningless unless they are ways to
demonstrate what we're really here to
accomplish MH and what we're really here
to accomplish is the fullest expression
of who we really
are people who step into
that
activity and come from that awareness
are people who Chang the lives of
everyone whose life they touch and rule
number six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is celebrate forgive
and commit with Lisa Nichols just see
love just see possibility just see all
the things that you've come through and
then I want you to speak to yourself as
if you were your best friend say your
first name I would say Lisa say your
first name and then complete these three
sentences the first sentence say your
name first Lisa I would say Lisa I'm
proud that you and find seven different
things to celebrate yourself for and
they could be small things Lisa I'm
proud that you got out of bed this
morning I'm proud that
you I'm proud that you prayed today I'm
proud that you went to work today I'm
proud that you set a healthy boundary in
that relationship I'm proud that you got
out of the relationship I'm proud that
you said yes even though you're afraid
to LEAP about that new job I'm proud
that you got on the phone today with
your mother whatever that small thing is
that you can celebrate they don't have
to be big huge things remember celebrate
the micro winds and the micro winds
become macro winds and you say I forgive
you
for and go back 20 years go back 10
years go back 5 years or go back 5 days
Lisa I forgive you for getting in a
relationship that wasn't worthy of you
Lisa I forgive you for lower your
integrity bar and saying yes when you
really should have said no Lisa I
forgive you for endangering galani when
you got into an abusive relationship
unknowingly Lisa I forgive you for not
getting out sooner quicker
faster Lisa I forgive you for gaining
over 80 lbs being too stubborn to go to
the doctor to find out what was really
wrong Lisa I forgive you for blaming
yourself when a relationship didn't go
right and he left when in fact man's
rejection was really God's
protection but you blamed
you that second
sentence is liberating so sobering a
little painful and definitely free Lisa
I commit to you that today I will only
say yes when I want to say yes and I'll
say no on the days that I need to say no
Lisa I commit to you that I won't keep
score I won't collect evidence on why
life won't work for you our
relationships won't work for you or this
next eating plan won't work for you I
won't keep track I mean I won't keep
score I won't collect evidence why it
won't work I'll keep track on why it
should work Lisa I commit to you that
today I'll stop the negative chatter
sooner quicker faster and I'll go into
the love chatter sooner quicker
faster if you think money is scarce you
hoard it because you believe that no
more money will come to you if you know
money is abundant more money will flow
to you this isn't about being wasteful
does it doesn't mean you have to go and
always empty your pockets and buy a lot
of dumb stuff and throw away all your
other stuff it doesn't mean you have to
waste your
money but it's switching the mindset of
money is not just some scarce thing that
you don't know how to make that you will
never have more of and so you need to
hoard every single dollar that you've
got this is honestly something that I am
continuing to rewire myself on I
struggled a lot with money especially in
the early days of my business um even
growing up I I grew up in a middle class
family my parents spent my parents are
behind me on the wall hold on there we
go this is me when I'm eight or nine and
my parents here they believed in
education a lot and they didn't have a
ton of money we weren't poor but they
spent all of their money basically on
putting the three of us kids I have two
sisters through private school so any
money that they made basically poured
into our education and as a result we
didn't have you know money for other
things and uh where my friends at these
fancy schools were getting you know BMWs
for their 16th birthday so they can go
off and drive uh you know I didn't get
any of that and it's not what it was me
but it's more I just had a scarce
mentality around money in my first
business I was making 300 bucks a month
I was eating the same bean salad lunch
every day because it would fill me up
and it wasn't uh very expensive when we
celebrated a win we'd go to McDonald's
if we got a new client like hey we sold
another piece of our software we go to
McDonald's and order a large fries and
share that between the three of us cuz
it was cheap and we wanted just some
little way to celebrate
and I just remember how painful it was
to feel like you have no money and you
can't buy stuff and I couldn't hang out
with my friends and I couldn't do what I
wanted to do and I think that has a
traumatic effect you know I mean maybe
that's you as well you you have a
scarcity mindset around money that you
don't know how to make it and so
anything you've got you got to really
hold on to it and protect it and again
I'm not advocating for being Reckless or
stupid or just throwing money away be be
smart about how you're going to invest
and use your money the more important
thing is developing the mindset that you
can create money that by bringing a lot
of value to people you can make more
money you can turn it into something so
one of the things that I've done
recently that that um has helped both
myself and Nina my wife is we create
what we call a care fund and every month
when we're doing our numbers uh Nina
will put together how much we've made
this month how much cashs come in ETC
and then we allocate a certain
percentage for a care fund that we have
to go off and
spend uh either for ourselves or for
other people and so my default is to
invest invest invest invest invest right
like invest back into the business
invest into into into markets invest in
the assets just invest invest invest
invest invest
invest the and that's a that's a great
good mindset the downside of that is you
don't get to see the impact that it can
create and so said you know what we need
to dedicate a percentage every month to
go and help somebody else and maybe it's
help ourselves you know um on the
weekend Nina bought a uh very expensive
purse we went shopping bought a very
expensive purse we bought a Chanel bag
and probably more expensive than she's
ever bought a bag and for me it's like
oh my gosh you can't be spending this
amount of money on a
bag but it's worth celebrating yourself
so you know what like we earned that we
did so much work in our business you can
you can go and afford that we've also
used the money to donate the Charities
we've also used the money to uh support
our family and things that they needed
or wanted in their lives and it's
something that we have to spend every
month Nina ask hey can we just save it
so we can invest more and then that
leads to more in the future like no
we're already saving other money to do
that like it has to be spent every month
and so we we have to sit this might
sound crazy we have to sit down every
month and figure out how are we going to
spend this money because my default is
not to go and spend the default is to
invest or just to
save and so doing that it doesn't have
to be a big amount of money it could it
could be 100 bucks a month that you
force yourself to spend on making
somebody else's life better or even your
own like that thing that you would never
buy for yourself you know what I've
worked hard like I'm going to buy it or
you're going to go buy somebody a meal
or you're going to go and give a
homeless person $100 right like you're
going to you're going to do something
with
it because what it does is starts to
change your mentality around it it it
starts to make you feel
like more will come that I'm
creating and so whether it's 10 bucks
100 bucks 1,000 bucks 10,000 bucks like
you know whatever it is I'm not
advocating you go drain your bank
account and just go crazy and buy a
Chanel bag you know but allocating
certain percentage every
month so that you can start to rewire
your beliefs around money that it's not
just super scarce so that would be step
number one right allocate some kind of
budget to helping especially others
because when you can when you help
others it just makes you feel so good
and you can help others in a lot of ways
you can help them with your time you can
help them with your expertise you can
help them you know not just give a man a
fish but teach them how to fish right
but there's there's the immediate
gratification of helping somebody buying
the coffee for the person behind you in
line or seeing somebody that you know
that that 25 bucks 100 bucks will make a
big difference and like you were able to
afford to do that
that gives you the extra oomph to go off
and want to do more of it like if you
know that that 25 bucks change that
person's life imagine if you can give
them 2500 bucks but to do that you'd
have to go off and build a bigger
business right so the the core of your
business needs to be serving and helping
and contributing back and you can't
afford yet to give somebody 2500 bucks
but you could if you kept building your
business and so just gives that little
extra bit of motivation inent
right to get out there and start to do
it to allocate a certain percentage
second is to be around people who are
who are generous be around the people
who have the mindset that you want to
have if there's a belief that you want
to adopt the fastest way to do it is to
be around the people who constantly are
screaming that belief the people who are
constantly living that belief so if you
love my view on something great hang
around me more often there's lots of
videos you love Grant cardone's view or
Gary V's view or Oprah's view on
something the more you hang around them
and watch their content and read their
books and listen to their speeches the
more you're going to start to adopt that
same belief
system so if you want to believe that
money is not scarce then you need to be
hanging around people who believe that
money is not scarce because probably the
people in your life believe money is
really scarce and the people that I grew
up with believe that money is really
scarce closest people around me and so
it doesn't mean you stop hanging out
with them but you need to inject new
people in even if it's just through
YouTube videos of the people who believe
the thing that you want to believe cuz
otherwise you get pulled back down cuz
your environment has been created to
keep you where you are so if you want to
change where you are you have to change
the environment and it used to be that
you had to you have to really change you
had to go somewhere else you had to move
out you had to find a mentor to hang out
with and have coffee with consistently
now you can do it through through
YouTube I've been inspired by tons of
mentors who I've never
met because of the content that I've
learned from them on YouTube but it
takes the effort and intention to be
consistently around it that this is the
belief system that you want to have you
need to create that habit for yourself
from the things that are on the wall to
the clothes that you wear to the the
media that you're consuming every day
being intentional with that to say this
is this this is the belief system that I
want to have I recognize I'm not there
yet but this is this belief system I
want to have and I want to be around the
people who believe this to their core
because they're belief in that thing is
stronger than your belief against it and
whoever is more confident wins and so
when you're around the people who
believe that thing so much they will
pull you towards them to start having
that similar belief system and then
everything starts to change I think
having a scarcity mindset is extremely
limiting I've I've lived through really
intense versions of it I still feel like
I'm coming out of it I've grown a lot
compared to where I used to be but still
have a lot a long ways to go I probably
still have
things that I'm holding on to that I
shouldn't uh I probably still should be
more generous than I am um and I'm I'm
working through it as well I might just
be a little bit further ahead on the
curve definitely compared to 19-year-old
Evan who thought money was the most
scarce thing in the world when you can
learn to make that rewiring happen
that's how you start to change your life
so if you look at the people around you
look at their beliefs especially around
money and see what do they think and
then see where they're at in their life
compared to the people who have
different beliefs around money and where
they're at who would you rather be and
you could be there you could be that
person if you start to change your
beliefs your environment start to help
more people with it start to allow the
money to flow because when you start to
believe that you can create a lot more
money for yourself
a lot of things start to change I know
you all have big goals Big Dreams big
aspirations just like I do You' got
Ambitions to become an amazing person to
build your career to create to
contribute to give to be an awesome
human being but all of that is
impossible without great habits set up
if you don't have routine and structure
set up in a way that will keep you on
track then you you'll fall off and and
and having new goals without new habits
is kind of like you know having a new
car without Wheels you know the habits
are the wheels they're the things that
make you able to achieve the goals so
you got to have good habits but the
challenge for most people isn't that
knowledge I mean you know you need to
have good habits it's you can't keep the
Habit going right have you ever started
it the new year you're going to get
healthier and you start that habit of
working out on a more regular basis and
then it goes away or you say you know
I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover and you start being nice for
two or or three days and then on the
fourth day you're a jerk you know and
you're like what what happened I said I
was going to be nicer it's that you
didn't set up the most important thing
you needed to maintain a habit so what's
the biggest secret I've learned in
almost 20 years in this field it's so
simple but most people don't have it
it's called trigger moments you have to
set up trigger moments to activate your
habits what do I mean by that well let's
say you want to become a a better person
you know you want to become more kind
more patient more loving with people now
you can just set that intention or write
that down in your vision your journal or
set up on a vision board that you look
at once in a while but in daytoday life
it's not enough you need things to
trigger you to remind you to be that
particular kind of person right it's
almost like if you could have a little
angel speaking in your ear all day long
to tell you what to do and how to be
you'd obviously become better well that
makes sense well let's use that idea
let's use that idea by setting up alarms
on our phones that trigger us to do the
very things we need to do this is going
to be so basic you're going to laugh and
then I'll also tell you how I literally
taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs and they
said it was the one thing that changed
their life the most dramatically so
let's start with this let's have a goal
in mind let's say you want to become
more present and calm throughout the day
again again you could write that down on
a journal I'm going to be more present
and calm you could meditate in the
morning say today I'm going to be more
present and calm and you you could you
can start out with good intentions but
those fall apart without a trigger
moment set up throughout the day to
remind you that so what if you did this
what if you just set up on your phone
three alarms during the day with a label
that said close your
eyes take 10 deep breaths in remind
yourself to be calm so let's say you're
going through your day it's crazy right
it's 10:00 a.m. and all a sudden Bing
your phone goes off you look down and it
says close your eyes take 10 deep
breaths and then again it happens at
2:00 and again it happens at 6:00 p.m.
and again it happens at 8:00 p.m. what's
going to happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that that changed
everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll forget
about it no that alarm will go off you
forgot you set the dang alarm there it
goes off in your face and you're like
all right I'm trying to be calmer and
more present close my eyes take 10 deep
breaths reground myself here we go you
can't do it once a day you have to have
moments throughout the day that trigger
you to enact the new Behavior I know
this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people cuz they
never set those things up so what if you
did it with an alarm so for example for
me on the opposite Spectrum I don't want
to just be calmer and more present I
Want More Energy throughout the day so
here's what I do one of my big trigger
moments is every time my butt hits a
chair I don't care if I'm on a plane or
I was like where we're shooting here I I
wrote a lot of my books here I wrote the
motivation Manifesto here I wrote The
Charge here and if I'm going to right my
butt hits the chair I grab my phone I
open the timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzing and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just 2 to 5 minutes
then I'll sit back down I'll set that
50-minute alarm and I'll work and what
that does is every 50 minutes it
triggers me to change how I'm physically
moving it changes my attention so that
throughout the day I'm continually
refreshed so I never have that 2 three
4:00 time where I'm like ah you know why
because I've triggered my day so that my
energy is maintained throughout the day
makes sense right this could be as
simple as let's say you want to be
healthier in your life okay let's set up
some trigger moments for you in this way
let's say every time you drop off the
kids on the way back to the house you
stop at the grocery store and get some
fresh produce that's just a trigger it's
like okay did one thing drop kids off
now tied to that triggered from that
action drop kids off is go to health
food store or let's say you want to get
healthier in the morning one of the
easiest ways to help people maintain a
better exercise program is this set a
trigger you wake up in the morning your
first action is to drink water put your
exercise shoes on uh might get dressed
if you were naked just saying so you get
dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
doorframe triggers what do you mean by
that when you walk into a new room to
have a psychological trigger go off in
your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
if I've been working all day and I'm
going to walk in I'm going to see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said the three words
said the three words and I did this so
many times that now when I walk through
a door my mind automatically triggers
those three words and I remember to be
those three words so what words would
you love to have describe you as a
person that you would be happy if that
was how people described you what would
those words be have those and now set
them up in your life I teach Executives
to do this as well I have them have a
doorframe trigger when they walk into
their office in the morning soon as they
walk through that door frame they have
boom three words go through their mind
about how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
every time they walk into a meeting into
the conference room room when they walk
through the doors of the conference room
they have another three words that
trigger off for them and it just reminds
them how to be so these aren't big crazy
things a lot of people they think they
have to completely change their life
what would change your life completely
is setting up more trigger moments and
associations that when you see something
you do this that when this action is
taken then that happens that when you uh
have the opportunity to set up alarms on
your phone you set them up so that
you're interrupted in your everyday life
to remind yourself to stick to the
habits to stick to the intention you do
that enough on a continual basis you'll
find yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes I
talk to so many smart fantastic
ambitious idealistic hardworking kids
and they're right out of college they're
in their entrylevel jobs and I'll ask
them how's it going and they'll say I
think I'm going to quit and I'm like why
they say to me I'm not making an impact
I'm like you know you've been here eight
months
right they treat the sense of
fulfillment or even love like it's a
scavenger hunt like it's something you
look for my Millennial friends they've
gone through so many jobs they're either
getting fired I mean and it was
Mutual or they're quitting because
they're not making an impact or they're
not finding the thing they're looking
for they're not feeling fulfilled as if
it's a scavenger hunt
love a job you find Joy from is not
something you discover it's not like I
Found Love here it is I found a job I
love that's not how it works both of
those things require hard work you are
in love because you work very hard every
sing single day of your life to stay in
love you find a job that brings you
ultimate Joy because you work hard every
single day to serve those around you and
you maintain that Joy it's not a
discovery but the problem is the sense
of
impatience it's as if an entire
generation is standing at the foot of a
mountain they know exactly what they
want they can see the summit what they
can't see is the mountain this large
immovable object that doesn't mean you
have to do your time that's not what I'm
talking about take a helicopter climb I
don't care but there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are
journeys the problem is this entire
generation has an institutionalized
sense of impatience and do they have the
patience to go on the journey to
maintain love to feel fulfilled or do
they just quit and on to the next dump
and onto the next ghost and onto the
next and by the way ghosting means the
lack of skill to have a
confrontation you date somebody for 6
Months 8 months and then just stop
replying just delete them from
everything now for the person who's
doing the ghosting oh that's certainly
easier than a confrontation but the
person on the receiving end of the
ghosting it's like there's a death
they're suddenly shunned there's Panic
they call out their worried they call
out their worried they think it's you
they think it's them
do you have any idea the destruction
that we reap on people by ghosting them
and then because there's the lack of
social skills to call out and ask for
help they internalize and it makes them
feel awful to the point at the worst
they will kill themselves slightly one
level down they'll get depressed but the
lowest level that we can hope for is
they will go through life and I'm not
talking about ghosting I'm talking an
entire generation that if we don't fix
this we'll go through life where
everything's just fine my friendships
are fine my work is fine you know same
old same old nothing's ever
amazing and the scavenger hunt
continues and then you go to the fourth
observation the most egregious of all of
them
environment we're taking a generation
that has lower self-esteem we're taking
a generation that has a lack of cop
coping mechanisms to deal with stress
we're C dealing with a generation that
wants all those things fixed immediately
and we're placing them in work
environments that values money more than
people do you know that most of the
business philosophies most of the
business theories that we Embrace and
see as standard today are not standard
their theories left over from the 80s
and 90s the concept of shareholder
Supremacy was a theory proposed in the
late 1970s it was popularized in the 80s
and 90s the concept of using mass
layoffs to balance the books did not
exist in the United States prior to the
1980s it did not
exist it became popular in the ' 80s and
90s the 80s and 90s were boom
years anyone could make money relative
peace a kind of gentle or cold war and
so all of the business theories they
were put forth were very very selfish
and all about enriching ourselves and
they worked for those times but these
times are different these are not
peaceful times these are not boom years
this is there's globalization in the
internet which has now made everything
vastly more complicated and those
theories do not work anymore worse
they're having side
effects it's really bad because what we
do is we destroy corporate cultures the
idea of using mass layups can you
imagine sending someone home and saying
I'm sorry I can no longer provide for
our family because the company missed
its arbitrary projections this year
that's what we're doing that's like a a
coach prioritizing the needs of the fans
over the needs of the players hoping to
build a great team it doesn't work we
dismantled things like the glass deagle
act glass deagle was passed after the
Great Depression to prevent another
Great Depression from happening it was
dismantled in the 80s and the 90s in the
name of
profit okay do you know how many stock
market crashes we had between the Great
Depression and the dismantling of glass
Eagle the answer is
zero and since they dismantled glass
deagle we had 87 the do crash 2008 we've
had three stock market crashes because
we removed the safety mechanisms that
prevent stock market crashes from
happening all in the name of individual
advancement and profit and these are the
corporate cultures we've built corporate
cultures that value numbers over people
and they are not standard business
practices they are new and they are
broken and they are dangerous and we're
asking a young wonderful ambitious
amazing generation that needs us to work
in these
environments whether we like it or not
we have to take responsibility for the
bad hand that you've been dealt it is up
to the companies to create an
environment in which you can build your
self-confidence it is up to the
companies to create an environment
in which you can learn coping mechanisms
and learn how to build strong close
relationships with people with whom you
work that you will eventually love and
sacrifice to see that they
gain it is in these environments that we
will learn the patience and the hard
work that it takes to find fulfillment
in our lives to find a sense of purpose
a sense of
Joy yes it's all fine and good that my
generation and older generation say to
you things like well you're the Future
Leaders we're the leaders
now we're the ones in control of the
corporate environments
now and we're making your lives
worse I don't want you to jump from job
to job to job to job you will never find
what you're looking for it's not a
scavenger hunt I don't want you to go
from relationship to relationship to
relationship what I want you to do is
stand up and demand that the places in
which you work lead you properly nobody
wants to wake up in the morning and be
managed we want to wake up in the
morning and be led and we have a total
leadership crisis in America politics is
just the mirror reflection we get the
politicians we deserve We're The Divided
ones we're the selfish ones we're the
broken ones we're the ones who would
soon to sacrifice somebody else so that
we may gain it's us and until we're
willing to do the hard work of repairing
the world around us our country our
politics our businesses will not fix I
think the challenge
that you have when you're good is that
you're good yeah so you're like I'm
doing pretty good already yeah it's e
the the better you get the more
expertise development you get the easier
it is to show up and go through the
motions yeah you don't have to prepare
as much you don't have to practice as
much you just you get results whatever
going to do is good enough yeah but what
happens with Hyper it eats at them cuz
they know they got more in the tank MH
and they're like you know what that was
good but I could have got another and
it's not that they're dis satisfied we
take on that myth in this book High
performers are not dissatisfied so
people who say never be
satisfied they got to look at why
they're saying that cuz it's not true
because High performers are satisfied
they're they're striving satisfied
doesn't mean they're not striving for
the next big thing want to become better
but they're happy hyperforms are happier
than all of their peers I mean by
significant almost double digits so it's
really significant um but I think for me
I need to constantly be reminding myself
like
okay what is the reason you need to
perform really well right now and I need
to be more consistent about that
question um so I set up triggers in my
life to do that you know um from every
time I stand in line I have a line
trigger I door triggers I have phone
triggers you know so when I stand in
line I always say what level am I right
now in terms of my presence in energy
scale one to 10 one I suck I'm dead I'm
not even alive not even feeling grateful
you know 10 I'm like I'm vibrant I'm
joyous here I am um and I I rate myself
consistently on that and it just
retouches me like the need I I want to
feel it's necessary to be grateful I
want to feel it's necessary to be great
I want to feel it's necessary to do my
best but you don't get that without
reminders so you got to set up alarms or
triggers or some you know note cards are
on the whatever it is takes for you to
have that but I know for me raay after
the research I didn't get how I mean I
me you're talking from every athlete to
every High CEO to this is what they did
they're and I didn't find this you'll
see all the questions I asked them in
the book I really had to dial into their
psyche and when we found that I was like
is that a thing that they really that's
I mean but they all do I would say maybe
not the most popular answer I'm go to
the fear how are you going to look silly
or stupid you're not going to ask
questions and you're going to end up in
the wrong place and people are like why
didn't you just ask like follow the fear
if the fear says I'm scared I'm look
stupid by asking questions like well
let's flip that cuz if you don't ask
questions you're definitely going to
look stupid those who learn to endure
hardship struggle challenge difficulty
pain grief vulnerability failure um
regret that's one side of that
coin if you learn to do that but you
also don't on the other side learn to
allow Jo Joy fulfillment satisfaction a
a sense of now hold on hold on I have to
stop you allow is that the word you want
to commit to you said bring I'm going to
build build it you have to first allow
it cuz what most people do is if on the
other side of the coin it's super etched
in what happens is even when that
impulse comes up to I like this oh no
I'm not supposed to like it this is what
so you have a lot of people who are
extremely talented at the top levels who
they do endure the pain and they really
like the pain and they will allow that
all the day long they'll allow that now
because they'll tell their brain this is
what's expected but they also don't let
themselves feel good when feeling good
is there this is a real big problem I
mean if you studied like psychosis a lot
of people who really struggle with
addictions um Eating Disorders are super
common who even when they feel that
sense of self-love or self accept oh I'm
not supposed to feel that no you really
there is an element to personal
development where you have to allow the
good feelings and not push them away
because it's like oh I should I don't
deserve to feel that because a huge part
of the world is telling themselves I
don't yet deserve to feel
happy even though happiness comes up I'm
I shouldn't feel that yet I'm going to
keep striving it's not until I get the
next two million then I'll let myself
feel happy even though they had that
good Monday and so you have a lot of
people who are striving in difficulty
who also have not taught themselves the
emotional side of what is called the
most important movement in the history
of the world in Psychology called
positive psychology kicked off by Marty
cigman a good friend of mine sent me
high without that work of saying no no
we also have to allow ourselves and
teach ourselves to flourish feel
satisfaction feel Joy so I'm 100% with
you and I'm like the rule is that's one
side the coin and the other rule is make
sure you teach
yourself to generate the positive
emotions because what happens is if you
don't teach yourself to generate the
positive emotions as well then what ends
up happening is you burn out or you
become a cliche of the person who had it
all and never felt fulfilled think of
your life as being a productively
fulfilling life
that productivity is not a a time
management
thing it's a purpose
thing I don't think of time management
when I think of productivity I think of
purpose I think of who do I want to be
what do I want to
contribute what will be fulfilling for
me because if you don't have something
bigger than just blocks of time which
are important but there not something
that we together are going towards where
it's this set of
Dreams where there's personal meaning
and there is social
contribution we won't go the first
lesson today in about sort of having
patience for your dream is you have to
work on it every single day for at least
30 minutes or don't fool yourself that
it's going to happen you know we all
hope that one day we'll get get a bunch
of free weekends or a month off or three
months off and that's when we'll finally
start working towards our thing you got
to do it every day what that means you
research every day you read every day
you study every day you take a course
every day or you actually create
everything on that thing every day
you're just working at it book authors
they write every day not all of them but
a lot of the greats wrote every single
day right and it's just forcing
ourselves to really be in the game now
not everybody writes every day not
everyone needs to create every day some
people can just have a marvelous 18 days
and they've written the greatest book of
all time but that rarely happens it
rarely happens and those folks tend to
be like Masters or savants or Geniuses
regular folks myself included I got to
work every day towards my dreams every
day I honed in something about this and
if you didn't know something about me I
do everything in this business right I'm
shooting this video right now but I mean
I picked the materials for this thing I
chose the fonts I designed all the pages
I mean I I wrote the back cover the
front cover the inside stuff it's like I
do the projects of my dreams let go of
the
baggage you're never going to touch the
full rim of your potential if you're
weighted down by baggage from your
Elementary School years your high school
years your college Years these last four
years listen the last chapters of the
book you gone through them you finished
them you flipped the page you got a new
chapter here and you have to be willing
to break from the past to have the
future you so desperately desire you
have to have the courage to allow
yourself to honor the past as it was to
forgive those who need to be
forgiven to forgive
yourself and to acknowledge that
everything LED you to this point now
everything those crappy times those
times when you're depressed those times
when you gave up up on yourself those
times when someone else gave up on you
those times that you gave up on others
the times that you quit the times that
you failed the times that you felt so
small you
embarrassed those times don't live in
this
moment and the more of those times that
you cultivate in your mind and you
ruminate on and you think and you selft
talk on and you revisit in your mind the
more disempowering times from the past
hurtful times from the past
failures from the past that you keep
running in your head what that is doing
is that is taking up the very free space
necessary for the Bold ideas to come in
it's taking up the space for the very
needed white space for creativity to
come in for the dreams to come in for
the best you to speak through
from like it's hard for you to live an
authentic and true and vulnerable and
real life if you're always always
speaking through your baggage if you're
always thinking through your baggage and
you guys know what I'm talking like
everyone's got different baggage maybe
you're may maybe your baggage is your
divorce or that last job they are not
relevant today and the only reason
they're relevant today is If either you
allow them to be relevant from those
situations or those persons revisiting
you or you're running the same old story
you're running the same old excuses yeah
I can't do this because I suck at
relationship no you sucked the
relationships 10 years ago well I can't
do this because you know uh I I failed
yeah 6 months ago today's a new day
homie like you got to access this day
dude this day is fresh this day is clean
this day woke up showered ready prepped
for you by the universe or Spirit or God
or luck or Cosmos whatever you want to
call it this day says to you when you
wake up in the morning the day Whispers
to you do not fear me for I have been
brought here for
you you don't fear the day that day has
been brought here for you an hour a day
to upgrade your mindset and your skill
set one hour a day is all you need to
set aside to upgrade your beliefs your
habits your attitude your perceptions
your emotional management and upgrade
the skills that you need in order to
play at the next level of success so if
you calculate 1 hour a day is 365 hours
in a year that equals 9 40 hour weeks 9
40 hour weeks after one year you're
really good after two years you're
really really good after three four five
six years of doing this every day just
upgrading your Knowledge and Skills with
expert information and knowledge and and
strategies and tactics you are in a
whole different place in your life so
invest one hour a day to upgrade your
mindset and your skill set so your
action set what you need to do becomes
automatic instead of something you have
to consciously try to do every day
because mindset plus skill set plus
action set equals your results you know
I uh I've just come through a really
challenging time I was in business with
one of my very best friends of 30 years
and we started a company together in
200 six or so and um he ended up with
severe diabetes and had a stroke and had
a heart attack and it went you know
everything just went in a hand basket
lost lots of money lots of um employees
we had about 70 plus employees we let
them go Clos the company down I had
friends of mine who put $2 million into
the deal I put a couple million dollar
into the deal and it was you know all my
intellectual property I developed over
60 years was basically held up in a
legal lawsuit that I had with one of my
shareholders and investors and it was
very challenging time wow it there you
know reputation IP start from scratch um
assets asset yeah lot so it was a
challenging very very challenging time
and uh fortunately because of you know
meditative practices staying staying
aware of what is not buying too much
into that I just you know started
building a new company over the last
four years and I've got you know 30
amazing team members now at our company
at neurogym um my relation my wife is
great my kids are awesome my health has
never been better I became vegan about 5
years ago stopped drinking alcohol 7
years ago gave up sugar about 3 weeks
ago let me know how long you keep it up
I made a decision now it's a year so the
one year no refin sweets yeah yeah no
refined sugar if it happens to be if
there happens to be honey on you know on
something that a little bit fine no
refined sugar no cookies no cakes no
chocolate bars no soft drinks nothing
well right now I don't have any Cravings
whatsoever zero wait till the holidays
you know what I just came back from
Montreal and and and I was there for the
holidays and the dessert table was about
as big as this and I just said no and a
week before actually four days before
that I was in Las Vegas at Encore at the
buffet and took a video of everything
that was there and I said now what I did
beforehand is I pre-committed when I
before I went to Las Vegas said now when
I go to the buffet here's what I will do
when I go to this restaurant here's what
I will do so I pre-committed in advance
played it over in my mind 105 20 times
put myself in the situation in my mind
and then when I was there it was easy
breezy cuz I had done it 10 20 30 times
so I did that and so when I went to
Montreal usually I go to Montreal and
all goes lose my mother you know is
always not anymore my sister's taking
over so the uh you know the food that's
there and um and the desserts that are
theref there too I love poutine oh yeah
yeah you get dessert but the desserts
for me is was the hardest part but it
was like easy breezy I own my feelings
and my emotions and my
results I own my feelings my emotions
and my results I learned how to be
responsible to be able to resp respond
to emotions that are unpleasant to
feelings that are you know yucky I
learned that whatever was happening in
my
world I had the ability to upgrade my
skill so that I can use everything that
happens in a way that serves me as
opposed to a way that hurts me or moves
me back any conflicts that you are
experiencing is going to create neural
dissonance in your brain it's just going
to create chaos in your brain and so if
you take it out of your head and you put
it on a sheet of paper you can look at
it and now you're one step removed from
what's happening in your brain and so um
the more you can be in
coherence it's the equivalent of being
part of a band that's in harmony that
every player is just like oh man this
just sounds so good well the more you
can be in coherence the more you're
going to be in flow and the more you're
going to take action the more chaos
there is in the brain neural chaos
whether it's because of emotions you're
lacking something there's conflict
there's resistance the more you can get
it out into the uh in front of you and
open and say well what's causing this
the easier it is for that Einstein brain
to say okay maybe I could do this maybe
I can do that but I can also call a
friend or a mentor or a coach or I can
research it there's a
misconception that business is easy and
I have a lot of clients of mine for
example there there are doctors and
lawyers and professionals that have an
expertise in a certain area but nobody's
ever taught them about Finance about
legal if they're not a lawyer about
marketing about sales about technology
about operations about management and
being an entrepreneur is like solving a
Rubik's Cube yes I see that right so you
can have the 2 by two with two colors
you know it's easy if you want a little
bit bigger business that's 3x3 there's
more combinations and more things that
need to be considered 4x4 now has
billions of different moves just 4x4 is
billions of different possibilities wow
when you get to the 8 by8 or 16x 16
Rubik's Cube there's quintilian of
possible moves that you can make so
building a business is all about about
recognizing patterns and knowing which
move to make at the right time and
there's four options that you have one
is do it yourself and try and figure it
out two is get help three get it done
for you or four don't do it a lot of
people ask me about money all the time
it's one of the things we teach people
how to do is grow their businesses and
how to make more money and they say well
you know I want to make more money I
said well in order to make more money
first you have to believe that you can
right then you have to believe you
deserve it then you have to make sure
that you have something that you can
earn money with so it's either going to
be your ideas you want to you can sell
your ideas
you yeah like a trainer um you can sell
your time you can sell your products you
can sell your services which means that
you have to have some
skill or you have to have somebody else
who could do it for you you have to see
your skill right well you have to either
see your skill or determine what skills
are needed okay and if you don't have it
get somebody else who has it to help
you and so when when somebody tells me I
want to make more money I say to them
let's say we have a pen I don't have a
pen here but if we had a pen yes and we
wanted to make money we could go and
find somebody who wants to buy this pen
yeah right now and how much is somebody
willing to pay for the
pen well if the pen is worth a dollar
maybe you can get a dollar for it but
what about finding somebody who needs it
because they have to sign a contract
that's due in 10 minutes that person
might pay $100 for that pen yeah so our
job is to take you know our skills our
knowledge our products our services our
abilities and to be able to present it
to people who need it and want it in
exchange for
money because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
# believe down in the comments Below on
this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
to learn the secret blueprint to shift
your reality check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there it is true that negative thinking
can be very addictive from my point of
view it is not caused by the chemical
that's generated in the brain although I
do not deny that the chemicals in the
body very often